merrill kelly just moments ago a scratch
from the start tonight
he has been placed on the injured uh
list with a right nerve
shoulder impingement riley smith
recalled and taylor clark will make the
start at the last second here
left head hitting rymel tapia to lead it
off
against the right-hander clark and he's
going to get it out here on a ground
ball from walker to clark covering one
away
here's trevor story the shortstop who
leads colorado with eight home runs
69 career games against the d-backs he
said 327
19 overs 50 rbis dangerous dangerous
hitter breaking ball hit well to left
field going back peralta
and it is long gone touch him all time
for trevor's story he loves hitting at
chase
field the rockies take a one to nothing
lead
yeah that went a long way and here's
nolan aronado
and nolan a sharp base hit to left isn't
that a good sign
so he's five for his last five after
getting a day off
here's murphy the first baseman there's
a ground ball to first walker's got it
he'll throw the second for one and then
back to clark covering at first now ryan
castellani
i wonder if the nerves are the same
that you'd expect if this was a crowd
full of people and many of whom he would
know including
his family probably not quite as high a
level of nerves
but it's still got to be there this is
in the air to
hilliard in right taking the place of
blackman
and he makes a catch here's could tell
martay hitting 336.
and this ball is lifted toward hanson
and center
and twice with his fastball he beat
calhoun and he beat martay
enough that he stayed off the barrel
good side too ground ball bobbled by
murphy recovers flips it to castellani
and starling marte
is out number three a 10 pitch one two
three start
for ryan castellani one hour walk and
the diamondbacks get the tight run on
base for escobar
rip back up the middle got into center
field for a base hit
walker is going to go to third and
they'll throw over there on the run
back to second out at second base
that's all nolan he knew he didn't
really have a play
on walker he went and bet the baseball
and fired to second tremendous play by
the gold glover now it's going to take
something from nick ahmed with two outs
to get a rod in
ground ball left side backhanded by
trevor story across the diamond
dugout by daniel murphy at first and
arizona strands a man at third the lead
single
and the lineup flips over to rymel tapia
and tapia with a soft liner that gets a
pass
martay and tony with a good read head
towards third he's in trouble there both
gets out
and tony will stay at third
and moving up is tapping i mean tony
walters did the full pete rose there
head first into third base but angled a
bit
toward the defender there made it look
like he was diving
for the bag but it looked more like a
die for the glove
and now they will walk around
intentionally so the bases are loaded
for murphy
this ball is well hit to right center
field
calhoun makes the catch walter scores
and the rockies have a two-nothing lead
calhoun lined out to right field his
first time up it looked like he might
have had one
into the seats calhoun swings hits a fly
ball to deep right field
back of the warning track back of the
wall touch them all
calhoun as that one's way way out of
here the diamondbacks are on the board
it's two to one
there's christian walker over the last
five the diamondbacks
are slugging 236. walker hits it high
down the line will it stay fair
christian walker say goodbye we are
tied at two well they hit one home run
in five games on the road here they've
hit two in two innings
walters into second base with a double
now tabby at the plate
bouncing ball to the right side grab no
it got through and into right field and
tony walters is going to score
it looked like martay was going to get
to that ball
but he didn't 3-2 rockies back into the
lead
calhoun the base runner and cattell has
fly to center and walked against
castellani
it's a home run in a silo and with drop
in nope topping
is there and calhoun back to the bag at
first out number two now it kicks away
from murphy cole gonna go to second now
they got him hung up
walters was backing up the play and did
a tremendous job
and they dropped the ball oh they say he
moved into it potentially
torrey's hot he is really hot with the
first base umpire
and torrey's not long for this game he's
gone he's just been tossed
from rob drake's angle it does look like
cole calhoun kind of leaned his head
into it like a soccer player and i still
am madly in love
with cole calhoun for doing that in the
first place castellani is still
out there for a six inning of work which
would be a high for him swag and a miss
he
got him with a breaking ball good inning
for ryan castellani now first and third
for murphy this becomes a very important
out for the diamondbacks here in this
bargain yeah this is a big one here
got him went to that slider kevin ginkel
gets himself in a jam and gets himself
out of it they get bad in the ball game
right here down one two one and two out
calhouny homer in the third
and this is a high fly ball to deep left
and tapia will beat the catch
oh
well we go bottom of the ninth inning
three two rockies they bring on
right-hander daniel
run out and here is nick that's a foul
ball
off the tone tony is hobbling and now
he's gone
down with that hit it is still painful
they're going to take him out of the
game and drew butera will
replace him the rockies are an out away
from snapping a seven-game losing streak
he's got him they'll finish the play at
first and the rockies win it three to
two the seven
game losing streak is gone